nos dicen que la relación proporcional
entre el número de horas que opera un
negocio y su gasto total de electricidad
se muestra en la siguiente gráfica de
acuerdo cuáles de los siguientes
enunciados son verdaderos selecciona
todas las respuestas que apliquen pausa
en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo muy
bien hagamos esto juntos y antes de
siquiera revisar las opciones dejen
analizar esto un poco esta es una
relación proporcional entonces sabemos
que el gasto total déjenme escribirlo
aquí nuestro gasto total va a ser igual
a alguna constante de proporcionalidad
multiplicada por el número de horas
incluso podemos descubrir cuál es esa
constante de proporcionalidad porque nos
da en este punto a sabemos que cuando
nuestras horas son 4 cuando tenemos 4
aquí nuestro gasto total de 120 120
entonces que tenemos que multiplicar por
4 para obtener 120 bueno sabemos que
cada debe ser igual a 30 porque 30 por 4
es igual a 120 de modo que podemos
escribir esta relación proporcional
donde el gasto total va a ser igual a
nuestra constante de proporcionalidad
que es 30 multiplicado por el número de
horas número de horas
entonces revisemos cuáles de las
siguientes opciones y pueden ser más de
una describe lo que está pasando aquí
opción a la coordenada del punto a el
punto a está en 4 120 así que la
coordenada i es igual a 120 es el gasto
total de operar tu negocio por cuatro
horas la coordenada ye del punto a
representa el gasto total de
electricidad cuando el negocio opera
durante cuatro horas si esto es casi
exactamente lo que acabo de decir así
que esta me gusta el gasto total de
electricidad es de 35 pesos cuando el
negocio opera durante una hora entonces
vayamos a una hora aquí este va a ser el
gasto total ahora ustedes podrían decir
que esto se ve muy cerca de 35 pesos
pero por eso es muy útil que hayamos
escrito la relación justo aquí porque lo
que vemos es que nuestro gasto total va
a ser 30 multiplicado por el número de
horas nuestro gasto total en realidad va
a ser 30 135 y en realidad se ve justo
entre 20 y 4
no un poco más cerca de 40 así que esta
no es verdadera y no vamos a seleccionar
esta porque ya seleccionamos una de
arriba terminamos hasta el próximo vídeo